and they do settle when they hit the  wall they settle when they've been  through too much stress they settle when  they need money problems they they  settle when when they when they that you  know what this guy's just on my case so  much let me just  all right  yeah that's when they said oh but they  they're really trying to get that main  guy and if that main guy came when they  are in a relationship with that the guy  that they settled  hi pergami bro they're gone no i don't  know  what do you class as that main guy oh  curiosity you know the guy  okay i'll give you i'll give you an  example okay  most girls that i know  even there's one guy that they just like  really deeply loved right and they loved  more than all of their other exes and  they could be dating the next guy or the  next guy or the next guy but if that ex  calls they're back